we struggle in this country that on the
right and on the left that if you think
your cause is big enough that you're
exempt from doing math you're not exempt
from math if you're a Democrat you're
not exempt from math if you're a
Republican you're not exempt from math
if you're a liberal and you're not
exempt from math if you're conservative
you still have to do math and anyone who
can do math can tell anybody that knows
the basic business premises of something
like a social security system the basic
things that are laid out there or
something like you know the tenants of
Obamacare the processes that are being
put in place there it's fairly easy to
surmise with critical thought what's
going to occur and you and you know you
just have to be intellectually honest
enough to do critical thought and look
at it regardless of your political
leanings and you have to you know you
have to pull your head far enough out of
your politics to actually have an
original thought that's very tough for
people because everybody they watch Fox
News so they learn how to say what
they're supposed to say or they watch
CNN to learn how to say what they're
supposed to say on the other side and so
if you've got your little liberal
socialism think-tank you know talking
points down or you've got your GOP you
know Cato think-tank principles for the
write down then you've got your talking
points then you hadn't had an original
thought in years and that's really
dangerous because a it means you don't
understand the other side of the
discussion but be you start to think
that you can just yell loud enough and
math doesn't matter math still matters
you still have to do math so let me help
you with this as an example January the
1st every health insurance company in
America if they're going to operate is
required to take anyone regardless of
how ill they are as a customer and they
cannot charge them more than they charge
someone who's not ill and so
your 500 pounds you have diabetes you've
got cancer and you've had three heart
attacks you're going to say the pay the
exact same premium as a perfectly
healthy person that's the new law it's
one piece of the new law now that's good
if you don't have health insurance and
enables you get health insurance I
understand the motivation and the
nobility and the moral imperative behind
that I get that but that doesn't change
the math the math is is that those
people get sick more often and run up
more medical bills than someone who's
healthy duh and if they now have to be
covered by the same company that you're
covered by and they're required to take
them they no longer have the option to
say I'm going to turn you away they're
required to take them then the math
kicks in because the amount of money
that that insurance company was paying
out to the medical community is going to
go way up they're not going to pay more
out to the medical community per person
than they ever have before now let me
help you with that what they pay out per
person is how your premium is determined
plus profit it's called an actuarial
table it's a simple law of averages it's
a statistical analysis really not rocket
science you could probably do it the
eighth grade it's really not it's not
it's not super complicated it's just a
simple mean if you're decent with math
you could work your way through it but
it's a simple thing if you're if a life
insurance company has more people dying
than their life insurance premiums per
person in that same group of people is
going to be higher thus they charge more
for people that smoke than they do for
people that don't smoke they charge be
more for people who parachute than
people who don't parachute and so but in
this case that's no longer allowed
everybody's going to be charged the same
translation you are going to pay higher
premiums to keep the insurance company
open or they're going to go broke
because they now have to cover people
they didn't have to cover
for and they're known as sick people now
it's a nice moral imperative but it
doesn't change the math so translation
is your health insurance premiums are
going to go way up they have to it's not
a mad about it it's not a political
statement it's that I know how to do
math and I understand the basic tenets
of how an insurance premium is developed
it's not rocket science here well my
insurance premiums might not go way up
my employers may go way up well honey
your premiums that cover you went way up
your employer paying them might affect
your raise might even affect the
stability of your job because they might
not be able to pay everybody because
they have higher cost of operating their
business now and if that's the case you
might lose your job or you might not get
raises did you pay for it yes you paid
for it it's called a pass-through you're
going to pay for it employers aren't
going to pay for this they're not going
to accept less profits they're going to
cut expenses like not hire as many
people or not give as many raises and
it's real simple and so you are going to
pay for it well I don't have a job I
live off the government okay you're not
going to pay for it I was wrong
you're not the rest of us are going to
pay for you like we do on a lot of other
things in your life if that's you 46% of
Americans pay no federal income tax the
rest of us support you on all the things
that the federal government does half of
Americans don't pay anything into this
discussion so that that's another part
of the discussion so again this is not
an angry thing it's a math thing now it
makes you angry when you consider the
implications of it but but you can't you
cannot use that you can't use your level
of anger or your level of passion to
offset the fact that math still has to
be done here you're not exempt from math
and just because you think the Social
Security system is a good idea does not
mean you're right you still have to do
math in other words let me tell it help
you with this if I took you know we pay
into the Social Security system fifteen
percent of our income roughly and if I
took two percent of that fifteen and put
that in a mutual fund I would have two
hundred times more money than I'll ever
get out of the Social Security system
with the other thirteen percent if I
took ten percent of the money that I pay
into Social Security
I can beat what Social Security produces
with the other ninety percent that's how
bad it sucks mathematically in other
words obviously that money is not
invested it is sent to Washington and
promptly stolen by them and then they
turn around and pay it back out later
but the money that they pay back out has
nothing to do with what you paid in you
have a negative rate of return in other
words the interest rate that you are
receiving on the money you pay into your
Social Security account is a negative
interest rate you don't even get back
what you paid in much less any interest
on what you've paid in mathematically
this is known as sucks the technical
math term this sucks
it's horrid it's a nightmare and the
same thing is true anytime you socialize
anything anytime you force everyone to
get a trophy you force everyone to be on
the same playing field you force income
reallocation anytime you force that
regardless of how you feel about it or
what your moral imperative is you still
have the same net result mathematically
and so the more we look into Obamacare
the more we realize that we're being
forced to do this you don't have an
option you do not get the option of not
participating you're going to pay a fine
your employer's going to pay a fine your
employer's going to pay higher fees
you're going to pay higher fees you are
going to get health insurance
I feel like communism
some of you don't like guns I'm a gun
collector I believe in Second Amendment
so you don't like guns what we passed a
law that said everyone has to get a gun
it's a freedom and it's a right now but
what if we changed it and made it
mandatory you wouldn't like that would
you well that's what a lot of us don't
like this we don't like our freedoms
been taken away and when you do it with
our wallet it's the same as any other
way it's still our freedoms are being
taken away
it's communism it really is and it has
come to a head so we've got to mess up
there don't be a while where they clean
it up don't look for the shutdown to end
anytime soon this is the Dave Ramsey
show